the iceberg known as a68a
is one of the biggest ever recorded more
than four thousand square meters
it broke away from the antarctic larsen
sea ice shelf in 2017
and is drifting towards south georgia at
about 20 kilometers a day
it's absolutely massive in terms of
icebergs mostly icebergs when they're in
the open ocean
uh they tend to break up and go into
smaller icebergs this one remarkably
has remained intact and that is still
even more remarkable
because it's got quite a shallow keel
it's not very thick so we'd expect it to
break apart
a68a is about 200 meters thick
and one fear is that the iceberg will
run aground when it reaches the
continental
shelf around the island the challenge
facing the team
is to assess the impact something so
huge might have on the vulnerable south
atlantic ecosystem
so something the size of luxembourg is
going to be a massive
impact on an island like south georgia
which isn't that much bigger than
luxembourg itself
the iceberg is formed from glacier ice
and as it melts will release billions of
tons of fresh water into the sea
potentially devastating krill
phytoplankton
and other species low on the food chain
that in turn
could threaten the diverse wildlife on
the island
it's one of the most pristine places in
the world with the ocean of fauna at
its most vulnerable that's the problem
the scientists will employ two robotic
submarines to measure the temperature
salinity and levels of phytoplankton in
the water around the iceberg
they'll also collect and study animals
in the water
if we don't protect the oceans this kind
of events will become increasingly
frequent
and the impact irreversible greenpeace
and others have long
been warning of the effects of climate
change but say the threat presented by
this enormous iceberg
is one that cannot be ignored
daniel schweiner al jazeera juan osiris